vladimir putin ha denunciado hoy en el
foro económico de san petersburgo que
algunos países se niegan a comprar la
vacuna contra el cob y 19 por razones
políticas ante esta situación el
presidente de ruso ha anunciado que ha
ordenado a las autoridades rusas que
dispongan lo necesario para que los
ciudadanos extranjeros se vacunen contra
el kobe 19 aquí en rusia pagando por
supuesto una tarifa clara esto abriría
la puerta al llamado turismo de vacunas
sin rusia abre sus fronteras de una vez
a los extranjeros nuevos ingresos para
el país y también más publicidad para el
régimen de vladimir putin según los
impulsores de la vacuna rusa spondylus
esto podría ser a partir de julio de
este año cuando rusia comenzaría a
acoger a extranjeros interesados en
ponerse cualquiera de las dos vacunas
rusas que están en el mercado unas
vacunas rusas que han sido recibidas con
escepticismo por la población a pesar de
que el presidente putin ya se ha puesto
las suyas